[Music]
um yo yeah this I'm actually stoked on
is Elon killing everyone every person
waiting for the bus yeah so Auto Drive
he's rolling out autopilot
and the way he did it he just totally
self-driving that's what it is FSD right
yeah yeah
full Sand Drive
I've been working with the milk boys too
create an awesome pose yeah wow yeah
shout out to the boy yeah he's out going
rogue he posted that he left there he
like sold his steak and milk he's fully
out and he's launching his own thing
fully out fully out eh it's fully out
okay so this is what I wanted so first
of all Elon just tweets he goes
FSD is good we're gonna you know you can
upgrade your car to have it all right so
here's the thing here's how Tesla solves
a self-driving crash dilemma can we
increase the text size thank you
with very rare exceptions automakers are
famously koi and about Crash dilemmas uh
they don't want to answer questions
about how their self-driving cars would
respond to weird no-win emergencies this
is understandable since any answer can
be criticized there's no obvious
solution to True dilemma so why play
that losing game okay but we can divine
what you can use the surprise macabre
you can use that word like that yeah
I've never what's going on today but we
can Divine are all these written by AI
yeah well we can Define the lobe in
automation which is
we can Define how an automaker
approaches these hypothetical problems
which tell us something about the normal
cases we can look at patent filings
actual Behavior related situations and
other Clues a recent lawsuit file
against Tesla reveals a critical key to
understanding how its autopiloted cars
would handle the iconic trolley prolly
problem in ethics I like how they put it
in quotes the electronic trolley problem
I like how I wish they put it just the
quotes are on the problem
we don't need every pedestrian yeah
yeah
okay
it it'd be this article be so much
easier to read if there weren't [ __ ]
90 ads on the right hand side
no I like reading my articles three
words at a time yeah it's like a haiku
yeah do you do you remember that day
when you day when you lost your mind
the trolley problem Loeb Macabre excuse
me okay do you remember that day when
you lost your mind you aimed your car at
five random people down the road what by
the time you realize what you were doing
it was too late to break thankfully your
autonomous sorry
save their lives by grabbing the Wheel
from you and swerving to the right
yeah into a deer too bad
for that that doesn't say that no
directly into a moose what yeah I'm
gonna set my Moose's body rag dolls in
the air I'm gonna set my Tesla to go
faster when it sees a moose
like like going through the settings in
your new Tesla moose settings what the
[ __ ] is that yeah click on it what speed
would I like my Tesla to to hit if it
sees a moose I don't know 188 Max why
does this thing go yeah yeah it just
goes fast faster fastest Ragdoll yeah
I'll turn that on
this goes [ __ ] Formula E dump the
battery mode
unloads the entire charge
just a crazy torque
I was trying to find this morning I was
trying to find videos of moose of Mis
attacking humans oh to justify our case
yeah I was like I wanted to like bring
those up and be like see look
like we we cover both sides of this you
know and uh the one I found was just
really horrible
what would it do I didn't even want to
send it because it was just like it was
on Not Safe For Life the subreddit yeah
and it was like this moose attacks this
guy
which is like all right let's go you
know yeah it's like POV of this guy I
don't know why the [ __ ] he's wearing a
body cam but it's like he's like out
snowmobiling and he like runs into this
moose not with the snowmobile
unfortunately but stops in front of it
stoked
and the Moose like charges him and kind
of attacks him and the guy's like oh ah
and I was like whoa that was crazy and
then he tries it again the dude shoots
the moves oh yeah dude
was that OV Izzy or Ashley who was that
that's exactly how I felt yeah I was
like oh man this isn't funny at all
I'd have been like whoa yeah
yeah
really you wish I mean I definitely no
no good good no incriminate yourself no
no what is it what is it so do you wish
I would have sent it to you no no no I
don't need to see it I did see this guy
in Spain get attacked by a wild boar
okay that was crazy it was like a video
game like POV he like whips out a
shotgun and I want to say I remember him
with like a
it was like oh what's that style you
call it where like
no not pomp where like breaks in two
pieces okay yeah you gotta that was pop
out like it was like it was like a Doom
2 style shotgun that's how it looked
it's just like the bore is like charging
ads like
ah just takes it out I was like wow why
would you even have that gun
that's the like a while yeah Gaston out
there yeah Belle was like you're not my
type he's like [ __ ] this
I'm killing Pumbaa
yeah yeah hunting rifle whatever
anyway
back to
animal murder car okay either action
here can be defended all right so this
is just kind of proposing a situation
where yeah yeah
um so it's like two bad scenarios which
does the car choose yeah I just want to
know scroll down I want to know
okay
uh by programming the car to retake
control and swerve the automaker is
trading a big accident for a smaller
accident minimizing the harm seems very
reasonable
by allowing the driver to continue
forward the automaker might fail to
prevent okay whatever
um okay so what does this have to do
with Tesla
to not use its automatic emergency
braking system when a human driver is
pressing on the accelerator pedal uh the
decision was blamed for preventable
accidents such such as driving into
concrete walls [ __ ] yeah dude yes
okay let's continue
um so what's the point of this article I
was just trying to see
like
because when we were talking about this
yesterday someone was saying that this
thing lets you choose
like which yeah bad option yeah
that's so crazy to me no
because it's like a split second thing
yeah
um
yeah yeah yeah
how many people would you like to kill
the car is an autopilot okay here we go
here we go
if the car's on autopilot or traffic
aware cruise control mode with no human
input it will or should automatically
break for pedestrians
uh based hope based on previous video I
don't think it does that yeah
and the automatic whatever braking
system is reportedly saved lives this
way already but this doesn't seem to be
the case when the human has control of
the car
uh as Tesla suggests in the previous
comments okay whatever
um
if that's correct it means that a Tesla
car would not retake control of the
wheel and swerve away from a group of
people or even break if the driver were
deliberately driving into them
okay
again this isn't a reasonable stand okay
I thought this was more like
or I thought it was going to be as the
driver you choose hit a group or hit one
I don't yeah I don't think that that
would
it doesn't matter because whatever
they've programmed is not going to work
yeah is this something where like
because I saw elon's tweet about it is
this new like I think I thought FSD has
been out for a little while and people
have been beta testing it
but is he just like Mass
like okay is this difference not fully
autonomous
um no that's the same thing FSD is like
the official name for it full self fully
self-driving I think fully sending
what I saw one of those in Canada so I
went away a fully self-driving Tesla did
you in Canada yeah what do you mean you
saw like someone like it was driving
like without a driver I mean there's
someone in it yeah but he wasn't
touching the yeah they were like facing
backwards on the car no they were just
like doing nothing chatting with their
passenger
damn yeah I mean this has been a thing
for a while yeah people like people that
have it buy those weights on Amazon that
makes it your steering wheel think that
your hands on it see that's [ __ ] yeah
it's crazy that's [ __ ] yeah yeah or
like the dude who like put the orange
yeah to put the pressure that's been a
thing for like a year yeah so now but I
know that was just for beta testers like
you had to apply to be part of that
program I'm pretty sure and they like
asked you some questions
probably will you use a weight instead
of a hand no no no okay you're in
um
but now I guess it's like uh rolling out
to everyone yeah it is everyone that's
paid for it that's scary maybe that just
means they won't have to like that is
kind of scary I'm never every time you
see a Tesla now on the street it's like
I'm especially as a pedestrian because
the one that I [ __ ] stay away from
that [ __ ] on the back like this is a
testing like fully self-driving car like
you know maybe they don't need to let
people know no yeah I'm never walking
uh in this town ever again yeah
you know did you do a lot of walking
before
uh well you know sometimes sometimes
we'll go downtown and you know park
somewhere and then yeah yeah that is
true I can't do that anymore that is
true it's like walking's not a really
big La thing
in general it's not but also like now I
don't even wanna
I don't know go put my trash cans out
yeah no I agree what if I put my trash
can on the Tesla across the street
blinks at me yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Nema Walid have them do they yeah damn
so you know they're going to crash right
into US yeah
whatever we shoot next just
sorry guys trolley problem am I right
okay the article says the point here is
not that we should halt work on
automated cars before solving Oddball
ethical dilemmas but it's to recognize
that by replacing the human driver with
its AI driver automakers are taking on a
lot of moral and legal responsibility
never had before just like that like
yeah yeah
I are but like the human would have
before right
um
but who's to say you know
your car is like a packet error and it
just takes out an entire bus stop
[Applause]
see that I would believe because the
amount of uh like programming errors in
my car right now is [ __ ] insane yeah
like my backup cam just doesn't turn on
like half the time from the car how is a
bug that glaringly obvious it's allowed
to exist yeah and I'm supposed to trust
the system that is supposedly
autonomously driving these cars yeah and
my [ __ ] backup cam doesn't turn on 50
of the time right
people might try to say it's apples to
oranges and it's not wait how is it I'm
just saying I think Tesla family it's
all just software yeah yeah I think
Fanboys would be like no there's a good
team I've heard horror stories about
Teslas too like just like the general
software that runs the car just locking
dogs in cars and kids and yeah
Yeah man so if there's a Tesla in your
city
ostracize it
put [ __ ] put a parking boot on it I'm
sure it doesn't leave that driveway
yeah we're telling you to vandalize yeah
no that's satire we don't actually mean
that yeah but it is funny to think now
that every Tesla
is now on par with a Mustang as far as
attacking a crowd yeah
that [ __ ] is scary man yeah next time
I'm in downtown walking to go eat ramen
and I see three Teslas at a stoplight
I'm not crossing the street yeah
it's like go ahead I'm gonna go in a
building and just stand inside that
building yeah you are the most yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah we've become the most
yeah
you are the Moose now